per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
momento sono fa vj oggi ragazzi siamo su
un errore incredibile perché dai tempi
di out las non riuscivano a baghdad a
molti lo definiscono nuovo auto non lo
so vediamo
sinceramente poteva anche evitare di
farlo alle 2 di notte pro non è vero
sono le sei del pomeriggio video bricolo
ci sei ragazzi su sembra veramente
outlast dalla partenza c'è anche la
videocamera siamo però su blair witch
del wii c'è un film incredibile uscito
non mi ricordo in che anno che ha fatto
cagare un ha fatto cagare sotto un sacco
di persone i tempi
io l'ho visto e a me ha fatto cagare e
basta era veramente brutto però è
giudicato come uno dei migliori film
horror della storia
non ho idea del perché ci sono le
persone che vanno nella foresta è la
ricerca della strega di blair
io sono il cane possa essere cane che
probabilmente l'unico che si salva nella
foresta a cercare delle delle tracce di
questa sera non ho capito che ce lo
spiegheranno loro che ne so io worth it
is pil che senso
no non mi farmi da rame che che poi un
problema ma come mi unisco alle ricerche
ma sta a casa c'è una [ __ ] al telefono
stare a casa
raga io sta cosa avevano messo riporto
pagane maghetta by ma posso aprire a no
interagire l'esponende schede troviamo
il ragazzino ne ho già passato
abbastanza ma scusami ma io chi è che
sono che non ho capito sono un
investigatore sono uno che ficca il naso
che ne so posso starmene anche a casa
volendo perché devo fare questa croce la
torcia va bene allora siamo import mamma
mia quante vite mi sono sempre veramente
tipo un horror fatto da dio allora non
che io mi voglio addentrare per forza
dentro le foreste cosa che non faccio
mai eccetto dal 2012 da quando faccio
video su youtube
però è una cosa forza proiettile camon
vai a fare il lavoro sporco per me
voglio trovare un bambino
c'è un bambino che è scomparso che
giustamente lavoretto poi lo campoli ha
fatto un mito vuole un'altra roba vero
allora vediamo come siccome con questa
trama si infittisce bella sa volessero
max
la strega attenzione c'è questo
asterisco tutto strano
è un asterisco disegnato da un bambino
va bene benvenuti su fa vj tv il canale
più adatto ai bambini di sempre
ragazzi se siete deboli di cuore non
seguito questo gameplay nostro
scherzando è rotta non c'è niente di
strano tranne i morti
io credo che questo cane sia una
macchina da guerra però potrebbe anche
non essere premici per richiamare
proiettile che posso richiamare il mio
cane dire il mio cane di andare a
cacciare finissima vai trovino
scoiattolo questo cane e bulletti il mio
braccio destro ascoltano quando a bayern
serve al linguaggio del suo corpo ti
avvertirà dei pericoli non sarà in grado
di gestirli il mio cane ricordati il suo
comportamento durante il gioco dipenda
con lo tratti stati vicino e troppa
solitudine può influenzare il suo stato
mentale dove cerca sgrida coccola fermo
le sta vicino praticanti e desing sto
gioco bellissimo il bruto cia cerca
comando cerca ho capito cerca e questo
cerca cerca bambino veloce di napoli
cosa facevate non gli dici neanche che
cosa sta cercando ricerca magari non lo
capisce se dice che è bravo trovato un
manifesto cerca cercati pari bravissimo
tutti 62 anzi l'iniqua seguono pieno
ragazzi vado avanti perché il mio cane
se non si sente solo nel frattempo è
arrivato un sms vodafone servizio
gratuito
c'è una caverna bravo fido dove è
sparito il cane dove visse eccoti bravo
ritrova la cavern in a ma c'è una palla
va come tra ragazzi bellissimo ho
giocato un gioco simile una volta
ragazzi dove il cane andava in giro si
chiamava barbie dream house party un
cappello bravissimo
nintendogs mi serve il cappello del
bambino questo è no bravo cane bravo
cane e smetto di peter che cavolo ma si
è riusciti a trovare veramente il
berretto del bambino possibile la pista
annusa 13 per mostrare l'oggetto vai
annusano che ti segue vai vai vai vai
trovarvi imboccava rimborso the boy come
le mani dove 69 seguire il mio cane giro
c'è un tesoro che altri ragazzi birca se
succede qualcosa al cane io disinstallo
il gioco non è uno scherzo
ti sto seguendo vai tesoro vai vai cerca
cerca cerca riscatto
ma cos'è c'è una collina maledizione
bravo tesoro sono quasi morto ti amo il
mio cane mi avverte sempre sprezzante
del pericolo
dove trovare il bulletto il modo di
tornare in cima
come mai la foresta è diventata così
brutta a un certo punto che è successo
cane maledizione una trincea sono in
guerra ci sono gli ex kong mesi e che ne
so anche solo per cercare è successo ma
io soffro di qualcosa tipo l'asma se
così può avere non vedo che nulla due
passi cosa è successo e cosa soffri
parlami non capisco
succedendo ragazzi cosa soffro
esattamente sono svenuto
ecco il cane e col cane
si è calmato
che è successo
ecco ecco ti stavo morendo non si
sentono capito cosa avevo però sono
quasi morto a posto andiamo andiamo
andiamo non ho capito che malattia ecc
associazioni cioè muore a caso dopo un
po sviene come ti seguo non andare nelle
colline per favore non andare nelle
colline su un casino
spett che mi chiamano non mi hai
chiamato brutto tra un totti sia posto
sulla loro passione orco per terra
tranquilla le donne che si preoccupano
per noi uomini perché noi uomini come ci
alziamo dal divano sveniamo per terra
però qual è un altro discorso
in questo momento sto cercando un
bambino nella foresta cosa che faccio
tutte le domeniche mio passatempo
preferito però non possiamo anche
parlare al telefono c'è già un casino
dover mio cane a fratello però non ti
devi l'archivio di allontanare che jean
casinò sto gioco per cortesia vieni qua
la tenda torcia torcia
no ragazzi sono tenda fermi tutti
insidierà sono bambini non riuscirebbe a
montare da solo magari ancora quella del
1994 che da baio camera ma non ci credo
davvero basta andare in giro annunciare
le riprese dentro non sarebbe stata
veramente uguale ad auto da ragazzi cioè
verbale della videocamera vediamo
secondo me non è una puntata dell'albero
azzurro 6 benvenuto nella casa a blu
sono svenuto ma come sono svenuto ma
sono svettando sono svenuto nella tenda
ma io non ero vicino alla terra dall
altra parte come buio questo poi è
successo ma dai ragazzi avevo trovato
una videocamera io promesso ma sta
ancora lì
e ancora riecco con la videocamera di
prima fa affatto finiti con qui ma non
lo so cioè che stessa dentro questo
punto guardiamo le voglio guardarla
anche prima ma si può anche vedere
cutini attiva disattiva modalità
notturna ma tra i che figata
quindi io posso ma io posso registrare
con la videocamera quindi no perché non
vedo chi ve lo posso vedere attraverso
videocamere a bra non come in out la
vedo proprio attraverso qualche armino
che figata cosa tabai successo
io devo seguire più o meno
sto riprendendo il mio cane in tutto
perché stai piangendo
si sta roba qua
distrugge per un arbitro distrutto
cosa che è successo cos'è sta roba qua
ragazzino ho capito acquisti così qui
impauriscono il mio cane carino carino
una sega
vai vai bullet cerca il bambino cercalo
secondo voi ragazzi io faccio prova a
predire un pochettino comanda la storia
tanto non dura tantissimo questo gioco
apple pochi episodi ti potrò 4 però
secondo me il bambino io lo trovo vivo e
ve lo do portare appresso una certa è
una certa perderlo il cane sicuro
successo perso il cane ma iniziano
persol cane ma ti pare che sono riuscito
aperto eccoti ma poi maledizione anno
trovo perché ci hai questi problemi di
vista ma edizione non lo vedo ma so che
sono proprio stupido non riscontrò non
riesco a vederlo perdere il senso credo
svenendo per terra ma ti vedo
tana di tua sorella malata
minchia come non me l'aspettavo ma in
questo momento fa schifo cos'è che era o
distrutto le cuffie va bene funziona
ancora
sono a posto e non capì non capisco non
capisco cosa succede cane dimmi che cosa
devo fare io sto venendo da mio perché
la mia testa è stupida quello gira gira
intorno cane punto extra smesso di
funzionare non regala ragazzi non riesco
a capire cos'è sta roba qua
fai attenzione a come si comporta bullet
quando ringhia c'è qualche pericolo
nascosto nelle ombre stargli vicino
durante i combattimenti tutela trovare i
nemici ma da solo e vulnerabile sono
vicinissimo cosa devo fare qua c'era un
tizio nella foresta facevo orribile c'è
un'altra cassetta mi sembrava lander man
in tutto questo veramente ragazzi
orribile
ok c'è un'altra stretta vai let's go c'è
il bambino che giocava a macchina
qualcuno gliela forte e basta quindi
dov'è stato questo trova la mattina di
nuovo così che cela giu ragazzina porca
vacca basta
ma dove cos'è sta ma cos'è ma sai che
non riesco non riesco a inquadrare il
mio nemico non lo vedo vedo solo una
roba strana che fàcasino una ragazzina
consentono
diretto da nora che orribile o gesù che
se mi raggiunge sono problemi io devo
guardare che cosa fa il mio cane in
tutto questo perché se non mi giro verso
il mio cane non capisco da dove arriva
bye bye bye bye bye bye bullet mi
servirebbe veramente una mamma mia ke ha
che ansia st parte
qui c'è veramente non è un gioco solo di
ricerche ci sono jumps che era quanto
pare va bene ma ron look armene
bruttissimo voi va bene gli avanti è
quello scemo dove chi fi no ti prego non
andare non a non andare quindi devo
parte lo strisciare qua sotto immagino
striscia così come faccio a passare di
qua
questi passa lo vedo il mio cane ma non
so come si passa c'è un tronco e un
albero amico mio vedo un albero e basse
striscia qui sotto performance striscia
so come ci si accovacciava non come si
striscia esso anna terio a si sa quindi
se io guardo il video adesso si alza st
fare può essere
si vede proprio che l'albero accade e
poi si rialza ma come che figata
l'ho fatto alzare quindi otteniamo su 15
grazie carina star o comunque che belle
come si dice nel tecnico che bei concept
insomma ma come come è possibile quindi
alla fine come se fossi in un mondo sono
entrati in un mondo parallelo ragazzi
cioè nel senso non ci troviamo nei me
nel vizio orco demonio stanno muovendo i
cosi occhio lo stai facendo non andare
di non andare via noi andiamo lì invece
ragazzine morì porca vacca c'è qualcuno
che mi sa occhio madonna ragazze
orribile sa fare ma cos'è qualcuno mi
vuole spiegare che cos'è quella roba
libro vi prego non ho mai guardato
madonna di dio c'è ori bile non riesco a
guardarlo ragazzi ori cos'è asca attacca
cane come tratto semi grassia inglobando
gli alberi ma un letto e stai qua guarda
il tizio che non lo vede
ma guarda tu per me hai capito vi posso
solo puntare la torcia e trattori fa
malissimo è arrivato un messaggio ma in
questo momento non è proprio il massimo
occhio che il mio cane si è intrappolato
nei rovi fantastico però non di segnale
assente perché sono queste salute
muoversi è sempre meglio che restare
fermi quelli che non si muovano il 99
per cento possibilità in più di morire
meglio far andare le gambe quindi cosa
devo fare qua via madonna che anzi sul
sito aprirlo cane vieni giù dai ragazzi
scopriremo cosa c'è dietro la porta nel
prossimo episodio sfasciate un bel mi
piace iscrivetevi al canale schiaccia
dalla campanellina per rimanere
aggiornati sui nuovi video che metto io
perché l'episodio bellissimo veramente
fatto molto bene per ora ci viene a
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]